so you're back in the WWE I've been back
on what for I don't know six eight nine
months something like that says in your
new book you and Vince were on the outs
well you know what he did he really
didn't do the right thing what do you do
wrong he he had a contract go ahead
what's your point you know they were
relying on him right and he just
disappeared he didn't even tell him he
wasn't going to show up anymore is that
true yeah it's a little more complex
than that you know
what about I guess you could say that's
what happened but I was having a lot of
you know health problems with my nerves
and stuff like that just all the way
back from 97 from the pile driver I got
the you know the Bruce spinal cord you
know I still suffer from that and then I
had three four fused uh c34 fused back
in uh 2000 did Vince know you were ill
no you know not not so to speak because
you know I just never played that I just
never never played that card dude I mean
you know just I just kind of kept it all
in you're one of those guys you just
you're a trooper you keep going well you
know that's just the way that to me the
wrestling business is you just go as far
as you can and then finally man it's
like yeah he shoots right on out of
there you start seeing the riding on the
wall and Bam you run into the wall yeah
a long way and you were the biggest star
of the WWE at that point besides the
rock now the rock wasn't even that big
at that point was he uh well he kind of
he started coming on after my first neck
surgery and then you know of course he
got really hot he did really well but he
happens to be a friend of mine you know
you know in this business you don't have
a whole lot of friends so you say to
yourself is Robin Wright you just said
you know what I'm out of here man I
don't care about my contract I gotta
leave for my health well it was it was a
the health reasons and then the fact
that uh you know on the creative end I
mean it's really buried me dogging me
with some really stupid stuff that
didn't make sense what was the worst
stuff you had to do well it was just you
know wanted me to go out and uh do a
match and of course you know I was going
to come out on the bottom end of the
match and uh they pitched as I did to me
while I was driving down to uh Columbus
Georgia to work at cage match with Ric
Flair right and I remember telling uh
Jim you know I said Jim Ross the
announcer and he gave the creative by me
and I said well you know if that's going
to happen you know I'm not going to be
there you need to change it they wanted
you to lose to some chump yeah and a no
build up match you know why did they
want you to do that you were their hero
you were the guy that's what I said yeah
it started spreading me a little too
thin so then Vince calls me that night
and he drives same scenario but I mean
you know by this time you know I'd had
about a gut full he starts telling you
why you got to do this particularly
imagine take the loss right and I
figured I'd done told Jim Ross exactly
what was going to happen if they didn't
change it and so when Vince pitched that
idea and it's about two in the morning I
was back in my hotel room in Atlanta
Georgia fixing to do the show there the
next day he got finished telling me the
little deal and I said okay well I was
saying maybe to him that's okay Steve's
cool with it me it was okay I told you
I'm not going to ask I'm hauling ass out
here don't you have to lose a few
matches I mean you can't always win but
you know that we're trying to work on a
kid and build him up Stone Cold Steve
Austin is not the first victim you feed
him I'm the last right there's money
there I didn't know you were allowed to
say you know hey I don't like I figure
they just decide your fate you're going
to lose this match you're going to win
this match I didn't know you even get to
be brought in on Creative well yeah I
mean it really depends on you know who
you are where you are on the system as
far as on the top picking order right
and you know Vince is always very open
listening ideas but as you can hear he
really doesn't have a say they tell him
so you just left no it was a deal like
where I do have a say but if that deal I
wasn't going to argue with him I wasn't
go the building and then present my case
and then get out of it there I just said
hey screw it I'm out of here when you
didn't show up for your mattress that it
Vince said that's it you're out of the
WWE you're done no no he didn't say that
as a matter of fact he uh left a message
on my cell phone you know telling me hey
if I got some problems give him a call
back and I figured out you know maybe I
just lip service I'm not calling anybody
all right so he you know stuck out the
the hand first but I just said oh that's
that's right they waited and
waited for him yeah so then it all
escalated into being about a six or
eight month deal so did you think
anybody did you think that was it you're
out of wrestling that's it I'm done
that's sitting there watching the
contract go close to expiring and then
finally I go to my mail one day and
there's a card in the mail from Jim Ross
just said hey Steve if I can be of any
help give me a call Jim Ross so I picked
up the phone and I called him right then
because you know he's again he extended
the handshake back to me talked to uh
Jim for about two hours on the phone
went through two two cell phone
batteries and he said hey man he goes uh
you know Vincent had problems with a lot
of guys before but he's always been a
big enough guy to try to bury the
hatchet and get things back together
right are you open to uh you know maybe
getting a meeting with him and seeing if
you guys can get back together I said
well yeah I said I'd like to go the guy
and look him face to face and ask him
what the hell happened right so anyways
about two months later and Jim Ross set
up the meeting it was just me and Vince
and highrise Hotel in Houston Texas
because that's where the raw was and you
sat down you told them look I got my
health problems I got this I got that I
need I want to be back with you guys but
I got to come out with a whole different
scenario it was a deal where you know
first when we got there is a pretty
awkward moment right and we just kind of
started just like hey talking about a
surface level stuff about the show then
finally leans forward he goes what
happened and uh and you told him yeah I
just told him everything and I just
started crying no you're a real man what
a time to start crying right so then but
really when he walked in I mean we
didn't know if we were gonna fight or
Shake cans or what right you know like
because Vince is you know you could take
Vince down can you pretty easy I think I
think the guy's pretty tough yeah but it
would come down to it for something
would have been fun if you threw him out
the window
this kind of uh you know then put things
back together and said hey if I do come
back probably basically in a non-active
role in you know as far as wrestling
goes but then as it turns out end up
later on that year wrestling The Rock
and probably what was my last match in
WrestleMania 19 in Seattle
foreign